what do you both say to the general
public who
see different things in the news and say
um it's too painful i don't want to
watch that i don't want to go there
but they know that something needs to be
done and
obviously you know both of you
ventured past that you're able to do
that in your part of photo right so you
have your own
organization what do you say to people
that i don't want to see that
i can't handle i think the film is done
in such a way gabby does a great job of
breaking it up with light moments with
some some humor
and also ends hopefully with the former
trainers looking at wild killer whales
as opposed to like another movie that i
love the cove which is really hard for
even me to watch and we were with louie
last night and we talked about that but
you know this movie i think is more
easily digestible
and i really you know i think gabby
mentions frequently that her twin sons
have seen the film
i mean i think it's a film that everyone
can see and i think that kind of
distinguishes it maybe a little bit from
the cove which is just hard to watch the
kind of the horrific scenes in that film
in this case you're kind of rooting for
the animals if that makes sense
and you see a little bit of trainer
injury but it's like you know
it's easier to handle for me at least
and the intention of it was very much uh
with this film was was with blackfish
was to
um just as as jeffrey's suggesting
the intention of the film is to is such
that children should be able to see it
and you know you're going to feel
sadness or you're going to feel
confusion but
every good documentary leaves you with a
little bit of anger
a little bit of confusion and some
questions and then some hope so i'm
hoping that this is sort of something
for the whole family
in its nature
you